[Music]  Celine Dion is that you or Lady gaga  yeah you okay are you okay are you okay  cutie  check out Celine looking nearly  unrecognizable posting this Instagram  pic debuting her new hairdo we had to do  a double-take as the singer showed off  fresh fringe banks and an equally  fashion-forward ensemble ahead of her  performance in Tokyo the first stop on  her Asian tour beyond fun and and magic  is his art and his fashion and it's a  lot of work Celine has been taking major  risk with her fashion and beauty since  she started working with stylist La  Roche in 2016 you have brought to me  happiness through my clothing so I want  to thank you for that as for that bang a  new look it might have been just a  temporary tweak Selene appeared on stage  at her Tokyo show with no banks in sight  but when you're the iconic Celine Dion  you can never go too big or bold  [Music]